mit ihrem einsatz bewegen mehr kultur
swisslos wünscht ihnen viel vergnügen zu
beginn eine legende
im herbst 1864 sitz der legendäre
hotelier johannes badrutt mit vier
engländern im hotel polen bedroht
erzählt vom traumhaften winter im
engadin und wie man tagsüber hemdsärmlig
draußen sein könne
die engländer glaubten ihn kein wort der
hotelier wettete mit ihnen wenn dem
nicht so sei würde er ihnen die gesamten
reisekosten zurückerstatten
die engländer kam tatsächlich im winter
und reisten erst an ostern wieder ab mit
braun gebrannten armen
dieser wette so die legende soll den
schweizer tourismus mitbegründet haben
nur gut muss der legendäre johannes
badrutt die korona feriensaison 2020
nicht erleben
[Musik]
die aus sankt moritz herzlich willkommen
auf dem kultplatz
[Musik]
diesen sommer machen wir keine großen
reisen aber sommer hat er viel mit
sehnsucht zu tun und die sehnsucht mit
dem meer
deshalb brauchen wir diesen sommer eine
symbolische see einem sehnsuchtsort den
wir erreichen können und deshalb
plädieren wir heute für das gute das so
nahe liegt
[Musik]
ja bald werden die grenzen wieder öffnen
aber auch hier in st moritz werden sie
nicht sehr zahlreich erscheinen die
internationalen gäste diesen sommer was
bedeutet das für den tourismus bei uns
in der welt wir müssen das reisen mit
und nach corona neu denken
wohin wird es uns diesen sommer ziehen
[Musik]
die ferne auf entdeckungsreise ins
unbekannte
oder bleiben wir daheim und verdrängen
das fernweh
manche reiseziele scheinen unerreichbar
zu sein david 19 hat die grenzenlose
mobilität eingeschränkt das reisen
verändert ein virus stellt uns vor die
grundsätzliche frage wollen wir reisen
und uns bilden neues erfahren oder
suchen wir fahren das schnelle pauschal
vergnügen in der ferne ein kleiner
feiner unterschied in der globalisierten
freizeit maschinerie für jan andrea
florin allerdings ein entscheidender der
leiter der plattform für unterwegs
propagiert reisen abseits massen
touristischer epizentren doch egal ob in
die dual oder pauschalreise auch
hierzulande oder zu weit entfernten
sehnsucht destinationen die
tourismusindustrie liegt am boden
keine gäste kein geld keine perspektiven
in länder wurde tourismus zur monokultur
worden mit dem ziel der konsequenz
erfundenen unglaublicher brutalität will
klickt sie ist der tourismus mit abstand
die wichtigste einkommensquelle vor der
luft und vom land wohl immer sprudelt
und gleichzeitig seine braut
arbeitsverhältnis seeblick er gerade im
tourismus und das führt eigentlich des
wortes die die schwächste am stärksten
betroffen sind
die ökonomische falle ist zugeschnappt
ob sich die hochburgen des
massentourismus erholen werden ist
ungewiss so hoch das infektionsrisiko
szenen wie diese für jeden virologen der
blanke horror spiel überlebt haben
touristen reisende findet man dort
selten
der song entstand vor der korona krise
heute klingt er nur noch makaber denn
wer ins österreichische zum skifahren
reiste kehrte oft mit dem virus im
gepäck zurück
tourismusmanager und gesundheitsbehörden
schlugen frühe warnungen in den winter
wind und ischgl wurde zum super-gau hier
wurde dem kommerz alles geopfert
vertrauen alpen idylle die idee vom
reisen
das dilemma vom tourismus er dort aber
tatsächlich leuchtet so stöger war es
reiseziel ist wo man heraus dass das
jemand gleich immer wieder dass gerade
genau darum die die negativen us
tourismus probieren doch davon ist im
moment zu wenig zu spüren
die ganze branche zeigt sich
verunsichert werbeclips weltweit
spiegeln ratlosigkeit und ein weiter so
signalisieren nur es gibt uns noch kommt
bald wieder die tourismuswerbung kenias
rät sogar zu hause zu bleiben
[Musik]
ein clip aus mexiko zeigt sich
optimistisch in mexiko und die schweiz
investiert 20 millionen franken in eine
kampagne um alte klischees neu zu
verkaufen
[Musik]
bilder die eine heile tourismus welt
suggerieren ohne existenzbedrohende
krise
dabei wären schleunigst alternative
tourismus modelle nötig
und wem es eben als wachstumstreiber
lockt denkansatz zu fehlentwicklungen
und zu monat oder für ihre und dritter
vor dem vor dem wachstumsdrang im
tourismus muss man weg eine andere form
von tourismus was denken die die reisen
wollen vor einem reisebüro in basel
warten wir auf potenzielle touristen
doch niemand kommt auch vor einem
anderen reisebüro
kaum jemand nur eine frau zeigt
interesse an alle sagt ich war ich denke
schon dass ich das wird an der situation
am flughafen im flugzeug die platte sich
anders verhalten
obwohl es lockt kriege gibt es eben nur
sehr distanziert und vorsichtig und
niemand das wird das ein bisserl ich
glaube es ist schon witzig unterbewusst
sie dass man jetzt vielleicht noch
wacklig dass man ab jetzt angestellt und
andere sitzt finde ich sehr schön blüht
können sowieso nicht so reisen und dann
finden die heimreise nicht und der
schweiz
selbst die reiseveranstalter wissen noch
nicht wohin die reise geht
im moment herrscht unsicherheit wie
sicher ist der strand das hotel
der flug praktischen agentur ist sie von
dritten
genau darum es geht darum neue reise
kultur propagieren und und und auch und
attraktiv zu machen
die krise als chance klingt abgedroschen
dennoch vielleicht ist die zeit des
nachhaltigen tourismus angebrochen des
wirklichen reisens was bedeuten würde
langsamer ökologischer und sozialer die
gäste aus dem ausland werden kaum ins
engadin kommen diesen sommer dafür mehr
einheimische gäste das ist die hoffnung
ja aber geht dieser plan auf und wo wird
diesen sommer unsere sehnsucht gestellt
hier im engadin diese fragen stelle ich
gleich dem wohl berühmtesten
gemeindepräsidenten der schweiz
christian jott jenny nicht die berge
sondern die bühne war lange zeit seine
welt schon als teenager organisiert und
zink der allerlei konzerte als
etablierter entertainer und tenor tritt
christian jott jenny in ihnen und
ausland auf 2008 er findet er das
festival
in sankt moritz und 2019 findet er sich
selbst neu als gemeindepräsident mit
glamour-faktor in ihrem reformeifer
sankt moritz machen sich das immer so
machen sie es in ca
als auch erwähnt dass der ruf gestanden
und ich hatte glück dass ich wieder
einmal mutter garderobe und wo gehen wir
jetzt mit aber und wünscht mainz
pression zeitung
besonders ungefähr 4 prozent weniger
übernachtungen sind prognostiziert was
bedeutet das für sein team
grundsätzlich bin ich gar nicht so
schlecht schlecht und grüne dem moment
klar ist die prognose aber mehren sagt
polizei die größte oder vorträge will
man mehr hand halt sehr viele
internationale gäste 50 nur kind und der
andauernden im ganze wird glaube ich
sehr sehr voller werden und und und
trefflich brüten erkrankt haben vorher
als touristische sowie weniger sagt
heimischem ein normalerweise gar nicht
die campingplatz habe sap im
tourismusbüro der säge bereits buchbar
in sankt moritz luxus peter nig sieht
das schweizer über 1000 camper sind
schweizer wo da sehen und campingplatz
wäre überragend überall im ganzen
engadiner ferienwohnung gewertet
überrannt und schlussrate naturgemäße
tritt roth & rau opera glaube ich dass
uns die im internationalen bereich eine
braune diese scheibe schlachter gebracht
und links das ist dann hörte die abstand
keine stifte zwischen
ist denn das schon fast in ihrem sinn
man eben auch campingplatz voll sind in
sankt moritz sie haben bis die gegen das
manko purismus aus luxus ort wird die
betrachter erzählte größter ich finde
vielfalt macht also ich bin mischung
zwischen hotel und campingplatz finde
ich es sehr reizvoll und sie haben ja
auch noch strategie oder das ziel dass
es mehr lieder an und sie träumen von
beach club fand ich gehört wo wir die
genese steht oder pittsburgh machen also
bis sandra p feeling da ein sankt moritz
aber so will ich dazu diesem fall
sie haben früher als tenor sind sie auf
der bühne gestanden aus profis an sich
ein dass ich einfach es wird davor sich
in der korona krise was jetzt hinter
sich brachte und dem was im vorwort ich
rangiert der frohsinn schweinegrippe
schaden von ca
das ist noch mit lustig kein schwein
steckt
[Musik]
leckere teppich nicht mein mundschutz
welt nicht verbirgt mehr mein wissen und
die frau lustig wie es mir genau die
frage stellt kann über gewöhnlich witz
machen und wird schrieb und ich brauche
im im alten schloss rooney das ist
absicht wurde das als das wirkt sich in
anderen fällen anders viel englischen
anders wäre ja sinkt das sind oft im
chor und der hat jetzt oft und lange
müsse verzichten auf das erlebnis so
langsam können wir gehör wie der
zahnarzt und wie es auch immer aber zum
das gemeinschaftsgefühl wieder zu aber
das ist schwieriger als man sich
vorstellen
[Musik]
heute nur in trier die bässe des korps
overload ab dem 6 juni dürften wieder
gruppen von bis zu 300 leuten zusammen
singen mit entsprechendem schutz konzept
versteht sich lukas bolt half eines
auszuarbeiten sich riesig damals
trainierte die thematik uns bewusst sein
dass rede mit verschiedenen stellen von
überall her fordert zwei jahre lang
betrieb zu machen jeder soll sind sofern
noch oder mehr weiß es schlicht einfach
nicht auf die sicherheit bis andere
bezeichnet er sich ja sowieso nur
verschwörungstheorie und dem in diesem
spannungsfeld bewegt muss sagt einen
tausch das streng also eigentlich bini
musiker mit leib und seele und unser zu
studieren
euro zone also kleinste wasser teilchen
in der luft die beim singen entstehen
sorgen für verunsicherung in der
kursziele
wie ansteckend singen ist hat die
wissenschaft noch nicht geklärt der
probestart umstritten eine
einheitslösung für 42.000 chorsingen de
in der schweiz gibt es nicht
hunger ist nicht gleich chor 1500 chöre
sind gemeldet in der schweiz etwas mehr
als es fußballvereine gibt mit gebotenen
abstand proben die singknaben solothurn
schon seit zwei wochen wieder unter der
annahme dass das übertragungsrisiko bei
kindern geringer ist
wo sind die 200 zum teil 20 mädchen die
einen kassen
es geht auch um die gruppe immer gleich
aus ich das mit mir machen wirklich
natürlich europa wo miteinander
musiziert autopilot der chor soll mit
der lockerung wieder mit 20 bis 25
knaben
[Musik]
knapp die hälfte des auf sauberes
das gemeinschaftserlebnis und das kann
man eigentlich nur mal miteinander in
der gruppe machen das ist auch das
zusammen schweißt
während des lok downs wurden chöre
erfinderisch es fanden digitale proben
statt bei vielen funktioniert das bis
heute so kanon der video konferenz im
live stream
die chorleiterin sinkt vor die
teilnehmenden singen mit deren mikrofon
bleibt aber aus sonst entstünde durch
die ton verzögerungen ein chaos auf der
einen seite wird das bedürfnis natürlich
sichtbar bei diesen virtuellen proben
die leute wollen singen sie vermissen
das aber sie erleben dass nicht in
diesem virtuellen singen der chor der
möchte gleichzeitig singen und das
funktioniert nicht
sie ist musikwissenschaftlerin an der
uni bern
christina und julia hat zur geschichte
der berner chöre geforscht treffen im
berner casino einer beliebten lokalität
für konzerte im neunzehnten und frühen
zwanzigsten jahrhundert waren manchmal
einer der wenigen orte wo auch
geselligkeit geübt werden konnte unter
gleichgesinnten will ich dass man nennt
und es waren auch institutionen die
angebote organisiert haben die man
alleine nicht machen konnte
man reiste mit dem chor nach paris was
man alleine nicht gemacht hätte man
besuchte den schwester oder bruder corin
palermo die große reise unternimmt heute
jeder für sich sozialer austausch ist
aber weiterhin ein wichtiger teil des
vereinslebens
so auch im coaching sie proben das erste
mal seit langem wieder in kleinstgruppen
der chor hat viele ältere teilnehmende
mit proben im über 20 köpfigen ensemble
wollen sie trotz der lockerung vom
samstag vorerst warten lukas bolt weiß
aber wie schwer der verzicht auf das
gemeinsame singen fällt wirklich schlimm
das ganze sehr lebens bestimmt schlimmer
will die junge hanna sozialkontakt
mitarbeit die dänische locker und gar
nicht so drastisch hoch und viele ältere
freut sich wirklich einfach unglaublich
die deutsche jahres probt das ist ihre
soziale umfeld und ihre ausgang und da
man jetzt nicht gerne mache und das ist
der herd die politik gibt grünes licht
doch die chöre zögern wollen einzelne
ihrer mitglieder nicht gefährden
augenmaß ist nun gefragt das bedürfnis
zu singen ist groß
und da ist es still
analytisch dass krones ist das zwischen
das ist ganz normal ich zwischen saison
eigentlich so sind viele die meisten
rote ist da im mai und anfang juni sind
sie immer zwischen saison ausläuft und
wann man sie sich dass elektrisches
gefühl dass ich vergangene epoche sind
die partie zieht vom schweizer tourismus
nbt
sie besteht aus einer vergangenen zeit
wo es solche schlachten vorstellen wie
das tron unglaublich dass sie sie muss
aber sicher trotzdem schön denen
unglaublich thronsaal nothelfer grüne
sachen machen und das ist einmalig da
geht es spielsalons im bau stützung von
bord und spielwiesen aber einfach so
unentdeckt sind
ich glaube hier also ich kann er sich
gerade in budapest dahin hat zu den
zahlen die dänen mögen das hemd
getauscht das ich so toll und jetzt
können wir da in den saal zum reden
zwang in der belag wird ja also das man
hat daher von karajan hat da eine probt
früheren darum das ist ja auch ihm
benanntes theater herbert von karajan
das sind prof durchführte beachtet diese
halle brauche ich nur keine timeline und
dass die trauer es ist relikt aus
vergangenen zeiten wo man tal wie es
glücklicherweise abgeordnet hat und wie
anders sieht natürlich dringend
renovierungsbedürftig ist aber das
verleiht ihm natürlich ein gewisses
haben sehen wir dem wunderbarer sal
tharani wieso das alles führt also ich
verbinde und glaube viele emotionen mit
dem sommer einfach vier jahre als musik
und für zu ehren von victoria hotel
victoria hat das konnte der für
mitmachen und frauen haben mit dem
festival jazz größere konzerte zu machen
das ist eine verdienste festsaal wo man
da oben sagt parits und es ist irgendwie
haus relikt vor der vorvorgestern klingt
gut die künstler am freitag freut sich
die gemütliche atmosphäre und kann ist
gefährlich wir sind system immer
ökologisch wo ich sie
es ist hauptspielort herz und niere
zentrum festival das haben wir jetzt
wieder transferiert und fotos machen
einige ausflüge ist balazs ist cool für
uster sehr viel und street konzept aber
einfach so das skore noch tauglich ist
da ist uns alles anders wird das haben
wir vorsorglich kredite tourismus muss
wie neue dank der im sommer was bedeutet
das bedeutet mir sehr viel spaß macht
das bedeutet sehr viel improvisation und
und spontane entscheidungen und schnell
die entscheidung sofort reagieren und
der lockige werde der tendenziell eher
besser aus leichter der glaube ist
hinter ordnung
positiv stimmt bleibt und da bleibt und
dankt malt mit probieren bis zu machen
dass man nicht ganz alles aufgeht
sie sind der bestens vernetzt sogar
schwarz 15-jährige hand sie ein jazz
dauer ist hält mainz haus in witzig
lauda und oder blick fragte sie das
geschafft haben sich sagt ich bin weg
hatte rhetorik hat sich ich bin mit der
tochter von george grund sieht 6
das ist ein schock sie das ist ja pcx
aber ich glaube das ist völliger bist
normal aus danke menschliche pc ja die
sind immer irgendwie irgendwann für
ihren tipis gut oder
aber wichtig ist dass man es gar nicht
einfach macht damit muss hat oder wie
auch immer gerade bis will sondern ich
bleibe beim bca flac der manchmal gar
nicht wohin sie privat sommerferien
dies sind vorläufige hat robert plant
und launig series also es gibt da so
schlachter zum sommerferien auch als ob
ich bin ein großer fan und der tat
rheine vom vom sankt moritz so maxi und
ich fühle mich am wohlsten im sommer
darüber sie 20 euro fast dankbar
[Musik]
wir haben ihnen ja noch das mehr
versprochen symbolisch den sehnsuchtsort
also im engadin und damit machen wir uns
auf den weg von großen namen friedrich
nietzsche friedrich dürrenmatt hesse sie
alle haben das engadiner sehnsuchtsort
geliebt
[Musik]
wir haben bevor wir da sind am meer
wollen wir noch ein letztes mal daniel
koch auf uns wirken lassen
der stoß sympathische delegierte mit den
schrecklichen krawatten der und
unerschrocken durch die krise geführt
hat und was hat er so gut gemacht dass
ihm nun sogar ein denkmal gesetzt wird
[Musik]
natürlich ganz und zwar ein geschenk aus
isenthal im kanton uri von einem
schreiner der heute holzbildhauer ist
natürlich sicher kopf von der fifa keine
augen die grausame oder was er dankbar
sind für seinen sport und post vom stil
her minen andere figuren beileibe nicht
wegen des bauchs dass hagel behagt
[Musik]
sein held ist aus lindenholz geschnitzt
leichte beute für die bandsäge rund 200
solcher figuren entstehen jährlich zu
schweinerei die schon großvater und
vater bissig genutzt haben
für die neueste auch der jüngste im
bunde drei tage
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die wette sei nicht mehr sehr rasch viel
erwartung dann relativ schnell zum
detail und die einheit noch mal das ist
schon so viel wagner schnell viel wasser
das entspricht vielleicht das leben im
charakter schnell fiel dazu kommen soll
dagegen durch einen spendenaufruf
während er die figur gratis erschafft
sammelt er bissig geld für daniel kochs
einstigen arbeitgeber
das internationale komitee vom roten
kreuz
[Musik]
über 14.000 franken fließen nun in
hilfsprojekte nach afrika
[Musik]
derweil wird einer zur skulptur erhoben
der vor seiner pensionierung auch
unpopuläre entscheide kommunizieren muss
so viel ehre für einen bundeswehr
ungewohnt in einer demokratie die ohne
polit star kult auskommt doch gemäss
bürger bissig verdienter lohn dass man
das auch die personifizierte ich denke
dass hier zwei gewöhnliche doktor
dadurch danke etwas irgendwelche abnahme
überbracht die unangenehmen situation
und so landet der hölzerne herauf
vielleicht gar im vorzimmer seines
zwischenzeitlichen weggefährten albers
hieß es zumindest bei der gestrigen
übergabe
und hier haben wir ihn gefunden unsere
sehnsucht so dass mehr den silbersee
hierbei sehr selten und schon friedrich
nietzsche meinte zu diesem alten hier
ist mir bei weitem am höchsten auf erden
damit bin ich einverstanden mit ein
bisschen weniger windhaus gerade jetzt
auf nächste woche da freue ich mich
schon sehr denn endlich gehen die
theater wieder auf und wir nehmen sie
mit
[Musik]
und sie verabschieden uns mit einem
blick auf das werk von christa oder
künstler starb vergangenes wochenende in
new york im alter von 84 jahren
und seine gabe war es uns die dinge
anders sehen zu lassen unter anderem
lisa uns sogar übers wasser laufen
[Musik]
realtech celtics
berlin 03 reals 4
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur ist
es los
[Musik]